Hello, this is Dr.
Andrea Kaladner.
The following set
of slides will take
you through the
history and physical
exam of the shoulder
and the elbow.
By the end of the
session, I would like
you to be able to
take a complete
history and do an
appropriate physical
examination of the
elbow and the shoulder.
You will learn how
to inspect, palpate,
take the joint through
the range of motion
and assess strength of
both of those joints.
We will review
some of the most
utilized
specialized testing
in the shoulder
and the elbow.
We will be able to
distinguish between
normal and abnormal
findings as
well as anticipate
and discuss some of
the more common
abnormal findings.
Finally, we
will be able to
document what we
have seen in a
complete yet
succinct manner
very quick review of
the anatomy as you
remember the shoulder
is a ball and socket
joint whereas the
elbow is a hinge joint
they're both
synovial joints and
you can have
abnormalities in any of
the following
surfaces The bone,
the cartilage,
the synovial
cavity, the joint
capsule itself,
the joint space,
the ligaments,
the bursa, the
tendons, the
muscle, the fascia,
the nerves, and the skin.
There are many
similarities between
taking a history
in general and
taking a
musculoskeletal history.
The OPQRST mnemonic
works really well
with musculoskeletal
history. However,
there are some
additional pieces of
information you have
to ask, such as,
have there ever
been prior injuries?
You have to ask
about the repetitive
movements either
at home or at work
or even recreational
activities
and in some cases
the patients won't
really know why
they have the pain
once you've taken
a complete history
you have to think
about what are your
potential diagnoses
the questions
and the answers
are going to
direct your physical
exam based on
what you think
your diagnosis is
ascertaining
where the pain is
it's not enough
to just know
that the particular
joint hurts
you have to try to
figure out whether
it's intra or
extra articular.
Is it within the
joint capsule
or outside the
joint capsule?
Is it a superficial
pain that perhaps
can be a skin
lesion or a fatty
tumor? Or is it a
deep pain that perhaps
could be a tear
or bone bruise?
I often ask a patient
to point with one
finger to tell me
where the pain is.
If they can't point
with one finger
and they have to use
their hand, that's
a very different
clinical picture.
You need to know
whether their pain is
in one joint or
more than one joint.
You need to
know if the pain
moves from
joint to joint.
You need to know if
the pain is constant,
intermittent,
symmetrical, or
asymmetrical?
And does the pain
radiate, for example,
from the back
to the hip or
from the hip
to the groin?
Knowing the onset
and progression
of the pain is
extraordinarily important.
You need to know when
the pain started,
if there was
an event that
the patient can recall,
you need to know if
the pain comes and
goes or has it come
and it's getting worse.
You need to know
how long the
pain lasts when
they do have it
and how often
they have the
pain throughout the day.
You want to know
if it varies
over the course
of the day and
if it varies
with activity you
need to know if anything
worsens the pain
or makes it better
and not just passive
things like rest
but has the patient
actually done anything
to try to make the
pain better have they
taken a medication
have they put ice or
heat on it have they
gone for physical
therapy or osteopathic
manipulative therapy
specifically ask
about what movements
make the pain better?
What movements make
the pain worse?
Whether rest,
ice, heat, or medication
affect the pain.
Quality of the pain
will often lead
you to the etiology
of the pain.
It's really important
to not offer any kind
of options to the
patient when you ask
them to first describe
the pain. The words
that they choose to
use are usually much
more informative than
them saying yes or
no to options that
you've offered up so let
them try to describe
the pain to you at
first and then if
they're having difficulty
then you can offer
some suggestions for
example if a person
says that the pain is
sharp and stabbing
versus dull and achy
that gives you a great
deal of information.
People who suffer
from pain will often
report radiation.
Pain can radiate up or
down and is not
necessarily associated with
the distribution of
the nervous system.
The longer the pain
has been present,
the further it can
radiate. For example,
somebody with
carpal tunnel
may initially
only have pain
in the wrist and fingers,
but over time the pain
can radiate to the
elbow and if ignored
long enough that
pain can even radiate
up to the shoulder.
When assessing
somebody whose pain
has been present
for more than three
months old, don't
get fooled by the
radiating pain.
You've got to narrow
it down to where
the pain started.
Knowing the
severity of the pain
will also contribute
significantly
to your treatment plan.
With musculoskeletal
pain, you have to
dig a little deeper
into the pain. You
can't just ask them
on a scale of 1 to
10, how much does
it hurt? You need to
know how much did
it hurt when it
started versus how
much does it hurt now.
You need to know
what pain level
usually is throughout
the day, but also
how severe it gets
during the day
visual analog scale
with the pictures
works really well
for most patients
it gives them an
impression of what the
numbers mean to you
and therefore you can
communicate pain
level a little better
associated
symptoms that are
local in nature
will also help you
come up with
the appropriate
diagnosis and
treatment plan.
If there's
swelling, redness,
and heat, there's
a good chance
there may be
an infection.
Is there
numbness, pins and
needles, and
local weakness?
Well, then there's
a good chance
that there's some
nerve injury.
Is there a rash or a
bruise, a hematoma,
a bump, or a lesion,
or a deformity?
And perhaps we're
looking at trauma.
Is there
stiffness, limited
movement, and
painful movement?
Perhaps we're
looking at a
degenerative
joint disease.
Does it hurt only
when they move
or even when someone
else moves it?
And has their
activity been
hampered by the symptoms,
including their
activity daily living?
you have got to ask
about associated symptoms
that are constitutional
as this implies
that there is a systemic
disease going on
fever chills night
sweats obviously all lead
to an inflammatory
or infectious process
fatigue weight loss
rash and generalized
weakness all need to
be directly asked about
musculoskeletal
physical exam is kind
of monotonous you
take the same steps
every time regardless
of what joint you're
looking at the first
step is to always
look make sure
there's no rashes no
lesions no redness no
black and blue marks
once you've looked
at the joint you can
touch the joint is
it hot is it boggy?
Once you've touched
it, you can ask
the patient to
move what we would
call active range
of motion because
the patient is
actively moving it.
Once the patient has
gone through their
active range of motion,
if it's not normal,
you can attempt to
move the patient
yourself through the
normal range of motion.
When you're moving
the patient's joint,
we call that passive
range of motion
because the patient
is not assisting you.
Once you've gone
through both
active and passive
range of motion,
you can perform
strength testing.
Once strength testing
is done, you can
perform the special
testing appropriate
for that joint,
whether it be the knee,
the shoulder,
or the elbow.
And oh, in case
you haven't
noticed, always
examine both side.
Depending on the
patient's body
habitus, you will be
able to see muscular
structures and some
bony structures
when inspecting
the shoulder.
From the back, you will
primarily see
the muscular
structures.
From the front, in
addition to the muscular
structures, you'll
also be able to see
the clavicle, perhaps
even the AC joint.
Inspect from both
the front and
the back. check for
asymmetry muscular
atrophy rashes
scars any evidence
of injury or
inflammation you
should be able
to palpate all of
these structures
that are listed here
bony landmarks that
you will be able
to palpate include
the clavicle,
the AC or
acromioclavicular
joint, the
acromium itself,
the spine of the scapula
should be palpable
as well as the head
of the humerus.
Acromioclavicular
joint or AC joint
is a very common
site of pain
due to separation
and dislocation.
another common
site of pain is
in the bicipital
groove where the
bicep tendon
can get inflamed
here you can see
the long head
of the bicep tendon
running through
the bicipital
groove afraid
to manipulate the joint
to get into a better
position to feel your
bony and muscular
landmarks as well as
attempt to isolate exactly
where the patient's
pain is coming from
previously stated the
shoulder is a ball
and socket joint
it has a tremendous
range of motion in
many different planes.
This demonstrates
flexion of the shoulder.
Here we see demonstration
of shoulder extension.
A deduction of
the shoulder can
have two different
definitions
depending on which
source you use.
This demonstrates
crossing of the arm
in front of the
body as adduction.
In some sources, it
will say that adduction
is the return of the
arm from abduction.
So from the 180 degree
spot down to zero. This
slide demonstrates
abduction, so abduction,
as if something is
being taken away, and
it refers to the
movement of the shoulder
from the arm hanging at
the side, being raised
out to the side to
90 degrees, and then
all the way up to the
top at 180 degrees.
Please note the
first 15 degrees
of abduction is
performed by the
supraspinatus and
infraspinatus,
after which the
deltoid takes over.
You will have noticed
also in all of
these slides, the
major muscles that
contribute to this
movement are listed, and
you should be familiar
with all of them.
Internal rotation of
the shoulder is the
movement in which the
thumb rotates in toward
the body and then up
toward the scapula.
Measuring internal
rotation is best done
by noting the level
on the thoracic spine
that the thumb touches
so in this case
we would say internal
rotation of the
shoulder on the right
to approximately t9
patient of course
is the opposite
so the thumb is
moving up away from
the ground toward
the back of the head
And again, the best
way to document
this would be
how far down the
cervical spine
the thumb can go.
Strength is
tested by asking a
patient to go
through one of the
ranges of motion
against resistance.
In other words, please
flex the shoulder.
The resistance
to that flexion
is offered by
the examiner.
We measure the
patient's ability
to push against
that resistance
in a motor manual
testing scale.
This should be
performed in all ranges
of motion when you're
examining a joint.
The reason we use
this is so that we can
clearly communicate with
other providers what
kind of resistance the
patient can tolerate.
So a zero would
mean that there's
absolutely no muscle
movement at all, not
even a flicker. So
a completely flaccid
muscle, something
that you would
only see in someone
who is paralyzed.
And then a five means
that the patient
can push against
strong resistance and
that we would consider
normal. Using either
the number or the
word is acceptable.
Now that we have looked
at the joint, felt
the joint, moved the
joint, and tested the
joint strength, we can
put it through some
specialized testing to
try to determine what
the etiology of the
patient's complaints are.
A crossover or
crossbody adduction test
will test for AC
joint pain. An Apley
Scratch Test will
check for shoulder
rotation, and a
Painful Arc Test will
check for a rotator
cuff tendonitis.
Performing a Nears
Impingement sign,
the examiner places
one arm on the
scapula and applies
a forward pressure
while holding the
arm up with the other
hand and applying
a backward pressure
positive pain indicates
an impingement
hawkins impingement
sign the
examiner holds the
elbow with one hand
and the forearm
with the other
Elevating the arm
at the level of
the elbow, creating
a rotation.
If this rotation
is painful, it
is a positive
impingement sign.
The test, called
the empty can test,
checks the integrity of
the supraspinatus tendon.
The patient is
instructed to push up
against the resistance
of the examiner.
and if pain is
elicited, it's an
indication that there
is inflammation or
injury to the
supraspinatus tendon.
To assess rotator
cuff instability,
the drop arm test
is very useful,
also called the
Codman sign.
It is performed
actively by the
patient in a
seated position.
The patient is asked
to abduct their arm
to 90 degrees and
then lower it slowly.
If the arm drops
suddenly or the patient
is unable to lower
the arm slowly, it
is an indication of
a rotator cuff tear.
The apprehension test
is performed with
the examiner pushing
anteriorly at the
level of the shoulder
and rotating the arm
in an external rotation
from the forearm.
The patient becomes
apprehensive
if they feel
that the shoulder
is going to
dislocate anteriorly,
hence the term
apprehension test. This
is a slide depicting
the Jurgesson's test.
Jurgesson test assesses
the long head
of the bicep.
As a provider, you
will be holding the
patient's arm at his
side by the elbow and
applying a resistance
to supination at the
forearm. your instructions
to the patient
are to raise their arm
away from their body
in an external
rotation movement
while trying to
supinate the arm
a positive test again
indicates damage or
inflammation to the
long head of the bicep
here are just some
pearls regarding
making a shoulder
diagnosis
remember that a
C5 radiculopathy
can masquerade
as shoulder pain.
If the injury occurred
during a sport such
as a throwing sport
or a racket sport,
you've got to
find out at which
phase the
injury occurred.
If there was a
posterior dislocation,
the arm was
usually in internal
rotation at the
time of injury.
And concomitantly, if
there's an anterior
dislocation, the
arm is usually an
external rotation at
the time of injury.
When we evaluate the
elbow, we take the
same steps as we did
when evaluating the
shoulder. So first,
we're going to inspect
the elbow, looking
for lumps, bumps scars
bruises any sign of
inflammation or injury
when we palpate we
should be able to
feel both epicondyles
and the olecranon
process the ulnar nerve
is very superficial
in the ulnar groove
and can be very tender
so be careful when
you're examining it
some common sites
of pain in the elbow
include the medial
epicondyle where you
will get a medial
epicondylitis same with
the lateral epicondyle
as well as compression
or irritation of
the ulnar nerve as
it courses through
the ulnar groove like
the shoulder with
its unlimited
potential for movement
and subsequent
instability the elbow
movement is much
more limited but that
makes the joint also
much more stable.
The elbow can simply
bend and extend,
pronate and supinate.
Please note the
muscles that are
involved with each
of those movements.
Pronation involves
turning the
palm down toward
the ground.
Supination involves
turning the palm
up as if you're
going to try to
carry some soup
with your supination
and then bending
your elbows flexion
and straightening
it is extension
again the motor
manual testing is used
to assess strength
in this case flexion
and extension so
now that we have
inspected and palpated
moved and assessed
the strength of our
elbow, we can go
into special testing.
The first special
test is the Tunnels.
The Tunnels is a
test where you tap
over a nerve, looking
for nerve irritation.
It is not only
done at the elbow,
it's also done at
the wrist if you're
looking for median
nerve irritation as
seen in carpal tunnel
or or in the ankle
if you're looking
for tarsal tunnel.
We also can do
a COSINS test to
assess for lateral
epicondylitis,
also known as
tennis elbow.
To perform a COSINS
test, the patient is
asked to extend their
wrist against strong
resistance provided
by the examiner.
If there is pain
on the lateral
epicondyle,
the patient may
indeed have
lateral epicondyl
similarly on the
medial aspect you can
assess for medial
epicondylitis also known
as golfer's elbow by
asking a patient to
flex the wrist
against resistance and
assessing for pain at
the medial epicondyle
so just a few words
about making a diagnosis
at the elbow the
extensors and supinators
of the wrist attach
at the lateral
epicondyle whereas the
flexors and pronators
attach at the
medial epicondyle so
inflammation at one
or the other of those
locations gives you
an indication of what
movements might be
painful and by all means
don't miss a tendon
rupture dislocation
or fracture here
is a list of some of
the diagnoses you will
come across when
examining the shoulder
The more common ones, of
course, rotator
cuff pathology,
glenohumeral
head instability,
bicep tears and
tendinopathies,
as well as scapular
pathology and
dysfunction.
Less common
diagnoses you'll
see are other
muscle tears,
adhesive capsulitis,
also known as frozen
shoulder, nerve
entrapments, and fractures.
Regarding the elbow, if
the pain is anteriorly,
look for bicep
tendinopathies,
pronative syndrome,
gout, rheumatoid
arthritis.
If the pain is lateral,
look for lateral
epicondylitis or
osteochondral defect or
radial tunnel syndrome.
If it's medial,
consider cubital
tunnel syndrome,
medial epicondylitis,
ulnar collateral
ligament injury.
And if it's
posterior, consider
olecranon stress
fracture or brusitis,
osteoarthritis,
posterior impingement, or
tricep tendinopathy. And
if you have any
questions regarding
this lecture,
please shoot
me an email at
acoladne, no r,
at nyit.edu.